la amazonía ecuatoriana es una
biodiversidad única en el corazón del
pulmón del planeta pero en muchas zonas
la amazonía es también sinónimo de
explotación petrolera contaminación
[Música]
donald moncayo es el director de un ave
de unión de víctimas de las operaciones
petroleras de texas
en esta región antes salvaje pero ahora
fuertemente degradada quiere mostrarnos
lo que hay bajo la superficie
[Música]
porque está aquí es el petróleo
esta es una de las 880 piscinas de
petróleo al aire libre identificadas por
donald
en esta piscina no es limpiada esta
piscina fue utilizada se beneficiaron de
esta piscina económicamente y la dejaron
y está hasta la actualidad tal cual como
la construyeron
en 2005 donald creó el toxic tour una
visita guiada para concientizar a
turistas y periodistas de lo que él
describe como un escándalo
medioambiental una manera de como
concientizar de cómo prevenir que lo que
pasó aquí no pase en otros lugares o sea
tratar de evitar este este genocidio
realmente por eso es súper importante de
que la gente venga que conozca la verdad
la realidad
en
1972 la empresa texaco que fue comprada
por chevron en 2001 comenzó a extraer
petróleo en las provincias de sucumbíos
y orellana
desde entonces según la uv de abt se han
vertido 64 millones de litros de agua
tóxica y 650 mil barriles de crudo en
los ríos y la selva cuando chevron se
marchó en 1990 sólo limpió una pequeña
parte de estas zonas contaminadas
todos los que yo tengo aquí en mi mano
esto
es petróleo
se trata de nueva loja capital de la
provincia de sucumbíos
[Música]
tú mismo
aquí es donde la asociación de víctimas
de la contaminación guarda los archivos
del caso chevron una batalla legal que
lleva 27 años el cerebro
pague el daño que ocasionó acá para
nosotros limpiar cómo se debe de limpiar
y vivir con dignidad como todo ser
humano se lo merece en este planeta
tierra
los alimentos y el agua se ven afectados
por los vertimientos de petróleo los
habitantes de las comunidades indígenas
y campesinas que informan de muchos
problemas de salud desde hace más de 20
años el abogado pablo fajardo libra la
batalla de las víctimas de la
contaminación contra chevron en 2018 los
tribunales ecuatorianos ordenaron a
chevron el pago de más de 9.700 millones
de euros para ayudar a limpiar una zona
de casi 500.000 hectáreas pero el
gigante petrolero nunca pagó y el
tribunal de arbitraje de la haya anuló
posteriormente el fallo
y si no también es decir la empresa
criminal en este caso chevron
oye a la justicia y en el mundo existe
una arquitectura creada construida para
proteger el crimen que comete las
transnacionales porque no hay acceso a
la justicia para los pueblos porque los
pueblos son invisibilizados porque los
gobiernen las empresas generan esa unión
que deja a los pueblos indígenas ya la
propia naturaleza a un lado
[Música]
los pueblos indígenas están a la cabeza
de la contaminación la extracción de
petróleo se ha realizado a veces en su
territorio sin consulta previa
tenía 6 años hemos escuchado sonido de
helicóptero hemos visto volar de
helicóptero sobrepasa donde vivimos
nosotros y después de unos meses ya
hemos escuchado ruidos dentro de la
selva y un día con mi papá fuimos a ver
que está sonando ese tremendo ruido
caminando en la selva llegamos donde
está talado bosque totalmente como 10
hectáreas de bosque y después de unos
meses ya hemos visto derrame de petróleo
en el estero donde vivíamos
el amazona se extiende por nueve países
de sudamérica
todos siguen buscando una forma eficaz
de explotar los recursos naturales
protegiendo el medio ambiente y a las
personas
a medida que se acelera el calentamiento
global salvaguardar la cuenca del
amazonas es vital para el futuro del
planeta
[Música]